there's no doubt that Poland is a
Catholic country with an estimated 90%
of its people observing the faith sunday
mass is still jam-packed
despite slowly diminishing numbers once
upon a time pope john paul ii held the
polish church together from the vatican
now eight years and two popes later the
pews aren't as full as they used to be
more and more people are turning away
from the church something that would
have been unthinkable a few years ago
but the church isn't prepared to let go
of its members so easily germans need
only declare their withdrawal to a state
authority in poland you must arrange a
personal meeting with your priest and
two witnesses as well as presenting a
written statement outlining why you want
to leave the church
machi moshevsky from warsaw is 35 and
translates into english for a living his
first attempt at leaving the church met
with failure possible start the priest
was very aggressive he scolded me and
said my request to leave the church
wasn't valid first I had to get a
psychiatrist to evaluate my mental
condition until I had a certificate
proving my mental stability he wouldn't
talk to me I was so confused that I
actually called to psychiatrists but of
course they don't issue such
certificates of Adachi it wasn't until a
year later that the priest reluctantly
authorized him to go but not before
calling him a lost creature at this
point much chefs Kees troubles had only
just begun
the model train collectors suddenly had
more time for his hobby than he'd
counted on
a shadow to the lividity shape my
neighbors spotted my feet when they
found out it's seen as a disgrace
everyone was very aggressive
I started making much less money as a
translator my customers didn't want
anything more to do with someone who
criticized the church a lot happened
behind my back the boss of one company
was religious so I was let go and
suddenly earned 25 percent less marcin
is not a unique case and many are
seeking to defend themselves a citizen's
initiative was founded in Lublin and
since the beginning of October placards
like this are being erected in big
cities around the nation their message
atheists are divine is designed to
provoke other placards serve as a
reminder that the separation of church
and state is anchored in the Polish
Constitution under Article 25
priests Thani suave makovski thinks
these placards are the work of the devil
he's suspicious of people who describe
themselves as divine after recent gay
and lesbian campaigns our visit is
another reminder of the next crisis
facing the church he says things keep
getting worse it's all very dangerous
these initiatives only seek to create
laws that suit them they act on a
conviction that doesn't speak for the
majority it's a threat to freedom a
demonic attempt to take God's place a
road to self damnation a huge danger to
Polish people to Catholics to our
homeland
it takes us some time to locate the
unassuming office of the citizens
initiative hidden down a side street in
Lublin they are responsible for the
placard campaign but are wary about
drawing too much attention to themselves
we often get phone calls saying that
Catholic nationalists don't approve of
what we're doing we're afraid that we
won't let our fear hold us back
still the threatening phone calls make
me nervous but they are still continuing
to fight against discrimination and
towards a life without restraints of
religion voice check [ __ ] Jeff yak is
fighting to keep his title as an ethics
lecturer in Chechen University he claims
that the rector terminated the rental
contract for his university flat on
account of being an atheist life as a
Catholic would be much easier it's
harder to get promoted as an atheist I'm
not looking to overthrow a religion to
burn churches or hang priests I just
want the right to say that I don't want
anything to do with the church spineless
people are swine's and I don't want to
be a conformist swine who does but until
it's made easier for Polish people to
leave the Catholic faith it's unlikely
that things will progress very far the
church still wields a lot of power and a
few placards aren't likely to change
that
you